hello dr. Peterson I've been trying to
listen to my conscience but I can't tell
the difference between fear willful
blindness or genuine conscience well the
first thing I would say about that is it
is quite clear that you are in fact
trying to listen to your conscience
because that's probably the first thing
that you discover so that's a really
good question okay
fear well here's a test and you don't
want to do this stupidly if you think
that you should do something and you
think that the reason you might not be
doing it is because you're afraid then
you should do it so that way you can
find out if it's fear you know I think
your question is will hi do I know my
conscience isn't just masquerading as
fear saying well you shouldn't do that
but it's rationalizing the real issue
which is you're afraid of doing that
yeah see here's a reason that you want
to tell the truth and I part I kind of
figured this out when I was looking
deeply into the Pinocchio story you know
in Pinocchio as Pinocchio strives to
become real he he has a conscience to
guide him but it's Jiminy Cricket this
insect but jiminy isn't really a very
good conscience he's a bit dogmatic to
begin with dogmatic and inexperienced
and so it's it's not like the conscience
is an unerring guide it's like a partner
in discovery and as you move forward in
your life and you consult your
conscience and you listen to it then it
gets smarter and so do you but there's a
coda there and this is why I've
suggested part of the reason why I've
suggested so frequently in my lectures
and in my book that people try not to
lie you see there are many systems you
have many systems within let's say that
guide you and what one of those is your
capacity for rational thought and then
you have a variety of emotional systems
and motivational systems and internal
dramas and intuitions and bodily
sensations like lots and lots of and
senses lots of systems that are guiding
you
and many of them operate you might say
unconsciously autonomously instinctively
implicitly all of that now you
nonetheless you program them like you
feed them content let's say just like
you feed your body nourishment you feed
them content and a lot of the content
that you feed them pertains directly to
your voluntary thoughts and speech and
your actions and then if you pathologies
those by lying so if you say things that
you know not to be true or you don't say
things that you know to be true when you
need to which is more common and if you
act in ways that you consider that in
fact act in ways you consider
reprehensible then you pathologize all
of those autonomous systems that guide
you it's like you're programming them
badly you're building an AI system
inside yourself really and in some sense
that is what you're doing that has very
bad it's very bad training data and so
the output it produces will be will
won't guide you properly and so you
don't want to pathologies your guidance
systems it's a really bad idea so that's
why you have to not lie and maybe that's
also why you have to say what you have
to say and you have to say it clearly as
well and you have to learn how to do
that
so that's one of the ways of getting
your conscience straightened out and
then you have to have a dialogue with
your conscience and you might ask it's
like okay well what should I do
or what should should I do this or
should I not do this so let's say you're
thinking should I not do this in the
case of a temptation maybe you have a
chance to develop a new relationship you
know and you're you're excited about it
and apprehensive about it and afraid of
it and you don't know how to sort out
all those feelings and the first thing
is you really have to want to sort them
out that's why you have to orient
yourself to something that's a genuine
up you know that the star above the
horizon you have to really want things
to be straight and you have to have
thought that through and you have to
know what it means for things not to be
straight and really what it means is
that you're headed for hell in one way
or another and if you underst
it's enough maybe it's enough to scare
you straight you really got to think
that through then you got to think about
how much better it would be if you aimed
up and that really has to kind of
permeate your whole being and so then
you're oriented that way you're oriented
up and you're deciding that it's okay to
try to tell the truth and then you can
start to rely on this dialogue with your
conscience but both of you have to learn
and you're gonna make mistakes along the
way you know that's okay you can say
well I'm gonna try this without being
certain that it's right you can even say
I'm going to say this without being
certain that it's correct like if you're
arguing with your wife or your husband
or your or your sister your father and
you have an idea about what might be
going on you can say look here's my idea
about what's going on who knows what
that idea might be contaminated with
like maybe I'm putting it forward just
because I'm too proud or arrogant or
angry or fearful or whatever that's
possible let's see if we can figure that
out but you can offer tentatively and
both have at it that's what you do if
it's a hypothesis right you both have at
it and see if it's an idea that's worthy
of of keeping can you do that with your
conscience and then you work move
forward there's a technique in
behavioral psychology called
psychotherapy called collaborative
empiricism so let's say that we you and
I have been sitting down and we decide
that you're gonna try something new this
week like maybe your Agra phobic and
you're having a hard time in a parking
lot and so getting out of the car and
going to the grocery store so maybe we
say well you know drive to the grocery
store and you're just gonna walk halfway
to the halfway from your car to the door
that's good enough for like do that
every second day for a week and then
come back and let's talk about it
so that's collaborative empiricism
you're running a little experiments you
think well your conscience is guiding
you towards something you take a
tentative step in that direction and
then you check and see well you know did
what I wanted to have happen occur as an
outcome that's the crucial question
that's the crucial question for
behavioural truth right that's the
pragmatic perspective did what I want to
have happened happen as a consequence of
my
framework of interpretation and my
action if the answer is yes then I have
not invalidate it right that's that's
the pragmatic philosophy in a nutshell
and it's it's very very smart so you
have a dialogue with your conscience
that never ends and hopefully it gets
wiser and you get wiser and that's the
dialogue that young talked about between
the conscious and the unconscious
between your your fantasy life say the
life that's sort of underneath you is a
conscious being like you the life that's
part of your biological platform the
biological platform that somehow
miraculously gives rise to your
consciousness if a dialogue with that
we're always in dialogue we're always in
dialogue right with everything so pursue
that